[Music]
it's not just a story about dance it's
really about characters finding a
nonverbal way to express emotionally how
they feel Tanisha Scott is a goddess she
is an award-winning choreographer for
some of the biggest acts in the world
I've worked with the likes of Drake
Rihanna cardi B Beyonce I just said look
I'm I'm bringing hip hop to the future
and I need somebody who can imagine what
that what the movements gonna be like in
the future she is a master of all
different types of movement and dance
and has brought that life to our
characters especially as they explore
the history of dance through the archive
and that's why I'm like I'm completely
in because you're not asking you to do
like the coolest moves anybody can do
that
but it's like now taking the challenge
of like how do you tell this story the
right story and give homage to a piece
of art that I absolutely love and
respect which is dance we see a wide
variety of styles of dance in in utopia
Falls we see from modern and
contemporary classical ballet all the
way to hip hop breakdance krumping we
explore flamenco capoeira so the state
salad dance is more contemporary they're
told how to move how to portray
themselves things change the music
changes and the dance changes and then
they have a moment where there
become enlightened with all this
information all these different styles
we wanted to tap into lots of street
style dancing where it's more about the
expression and telling a story and like
culture the cast's are wonderful they're
eager to learn and they're very
committed to their character that's what
I love this is that collaboration of
being able to hear from them where they
are in the story and the characters and
to make sure that they actually execute
emotionally through their body language
what it is that they want to convey I
love that Artie not only has a strong
sense of what he wants to see as a
showrunner but also as a director and
more importantly he's a director that
knows dance and knows how to shoot dance
so he challenges me to make sure that
okay so this is not gonna just be normal
I want to see Flair give me options tell
me other ideas that you think I just
want people to look at dance in another
way and to appreciate it in another way
and I want people to fall in love with
dance the way that I have in my life
you